[Musica]
nel 2016 mia nonna
allora novantenne per un artrosi a un
ginocchio rimane rimane in carrozzina è
un problema comune oggi nel mondo ci
sono più di 75 milioni di carrozzine 1
per cento della popolazione mondiale è
in carrozzina
un numero in crescita considerando
l'invecchiamento della popolazione
io nel 2016 lavoravo un'importante
azienda di ingegneria del territorio
stavamo facendo esperimenti e sulla
guida autonoma per le macchine
così mi sono semplicemente chiesto
perché non proviamo a portare la guida
autonoma dalle macchine alle carrozzine
e vi ha fatto partire un progetto di
ricerca e sviluppo
lo scopo era provare ad aiutare le
persone che fanno fatica a muoversi e si
spostano in carrozzina a diventare più
autonome dopo qualche anno di lavoro il
progetto stava suscitando interesse
così abbiamo deciso di fare una
dimostrazione presso un importante
ospedale della città la dimostrazione
andata molto bene erano presenti
istituzioni multinazionali delle
tecnologie e li abbiamo conosciuto una
persona molto coraggiosa
lorenza
il progetto di andrea a me è incuriosito
moltissimo e fin da subito ne ho
percepito le grandi potenzialità io sono
nata con la disabilità motoria che non
mi permette di camminare e di muovere
correttamente braccio sinistro
perciò l'idea di potermi muovere su una
carrozzina intelligente attraverso l'uso
di comandi vocali e quindi di poter
usare la mia unica ma non funzionante
libera per poter fare anche altre cose
mi è sembrata davvero interessante
così mi sono poi offerto di condividere
la mia esperienza con lui per aiutarlo a
trovare le soluzioni più adatte anche
per persone che magari hanno un problema
diverso dal mio perché poter usare una
carrozzina che si muove da sola o che
possa assistere le persone con
disabilità a muoversi in sicurezza
consentirebbe molti di guadagnare una
certa indipendenza
una volta capito che il progetto avesse
un senso anche per possibili
utilizzatori e non solo per gli
appassionati di tecnologie
ho deciso di creare una start up che si
di casse al 120 per cento a portare quel
progetto di ricerca e sviluppo in un
prodotto
ero già stato start up per sapevo quanto
fosse rischioso si dice che 7 start up
su dieci falliscano
ma avevo anche letto che l'età migliore
per fondare una startup forse 45 anni io
nel 2019 avevo 45 anni car devo
fortissimamente nel progetto così
vent'anni dopo la mia prima esperienza
da imprenditore ho deciso di riprovarci
accettata la sfida avevamo bisogno un
simbolo tutte le comunità di persone
aziende comprese hanno bisogno di un
simbolo un singolo attraverso i quali
singoli si identificano e sentono parte
del progetto per la nostra azienda
disperazione mi arrivò guardando una
foto di mia nonna era in carrozzina e
dall'alto al basso guardava la foto di
mia figlia che le stava seduto accanto
sul passeggino
quella foto mi ricordava tantissimo a
questa foto una volta una volta definito
il simbolo ma ci ha messo a cercare le
competenze giuste per il nostro progetto
e il fatto di essere nati a torino non è
casuale
qui nel 1899 nasceva la fabbrica
italiana automobili torino o più
semplicemente fiat
qui ci sono moltissime competenze di
mobilità e noi stiamo realizzando una
nuova mobilità ci aiuta a diventare più
autonomi carrozzine scooter per anziani
o i veicoli che nasceranno per smart
city domani e non vogliamo cambiare solo
il modo in cui le persone si spostano
vogliamo anche offrire nuove esperienze
di mobilità e se possibile farlo
attraverso anche veicoli che siano belli
in fondo l'uomo soddisfatte le esigenze
primarie mangiare bere dormire ricerca
al bello e nel campo delle carrozzine
non ci sono stati molti progressi negli
ultimi secoli
questa è una carrozzina del 1740
appartenuta alla nonna di maria
antonietta quella dei croissant né della
rivoluzione francese
ecco anche parlando di bello torino ci
aiuta stiamo lavorando con importanti
studi design studi che hanno fatto la
storia del design automobilistico
italiano e internazionale con loro
vogliamo realizzare nuovi veicoli che
rispondano esigenze di mobilità diverse
in ambienti diversi questo è il
prototipo per i musei questa seduta
appunto pensata per rendere più
confortevole lo spostamento all'interno
dei musei raccontando anche le opere
d'arte esposte offrendo così una visita
più inclusiva e infatti stata disegnata
in forma di poltrone e non di carrozzina
proprio perché potrà essere utilizzata
non solo da persone con disabilità ma
anche da chi per esempio fa fatica a
stare in piedi per lungo tempo anche
solo per chi desideri fare un'esperienza
diversa
io sono convinta che l'accessibilità
debba riguardare tutti e non deve
limitarsi all'abbattimento delle
barriere architettoniche degli ostacoli
fisici significa anche e soprattutto
essere accoglienti essere gentili e se
per mettere a proprio agio le persone
non sono quelli disabili secondo me
accessibilità deve non solo riguarda gli
spazi fisici ma deve riguardare anche i
contenuti
e infatti trovo che l'aspetto più
interessante del progetto sia proprio
questo cioè che grazie all'integrazione
della tecnologia a comando vocale
la poltrona potrà essere interrogata dal
visitatore curioso che durante la visita
magari
vuole rispondere a qualche dubbio
approfondire qualche argomento facendo
così anche una visita più personalizzata
e poi grazie anche alla guida autonoma
potranno essere presentate rivers azioni
di percorso per esempio tematico e
cronologico che verranno scelte
direttamente dall'utente in base al
proprio gusto anche solo semplicemente
la seconda del tempo a disposizione
a gennaio 2020 roda solo oggi dopo due
anni oltre a lorenza lavorano con me più
di venti colleghi bravissimi alcuni sono
anche quattro
lavoriamo un progetto che che ci piace
per il quale crediamo dietro le
competenze giuste che ci dà uno
stipendio e che ci permette di
migliorare almeno un po il mondo in cui
viviamo noi lo facciamo cercando di
essere gentili con chi va più piano in
giapponese esiste una parola per
indicare questa questa condizione
la parola ai big eye che in realtà
l'insieme di due parole che sono vita e
scopo
ecco questo progetto da uno scopo alla
nostra vita lavorativa si fa sentire più
appagati più felici il nostro corpo in
queste condizioni e rilascia dopamina
che appunto uno degli ormoni della
felicità e quindi la cosa scientifica
non è una teoria una teoria new age
quando noi siamo gentili facciamo più
felici gli altri ma soprattutto facciamo
felici noi stessi
egoisticamente verrebbe da dire siamo
più gentili che se l'assenza non sbaglia
saremo anche più felici grazie
[Applauso]